what do you think men don't understand
about what women want uh well they
definitely want somebody to I mean it's
very basic for me at least they want uh
attention when it comes to like
listening and caring those are the main
easy ones to be honest you don't have to
have the you know the giant muscles and
be six foot whatever that's that's a
plus I would say but the person it's
more like me I love
communication and I actually like care
about the individual I'm with so maybe
that's why it's so easy for me because
you know they they feel that I really am
with them in the moment not just you
know somewhere else you're not just a
yeah not it's not just you're not just a
stud who's there for sex you're you're
more of a companion that was that's
usually that's their first thing is is
sex maybe but then once um
um they get very comfortable like the
first day obviously they want actually
more just to hang out and be with
somebody you know uh be more intimate uh
tell stuff that they probably wouldn't
tell to their you know family members or
husbands husbands
exactly the the the interaction that
you'll have with your female clients how
long do they last cuz like very often
with the male customers of female sex
workers there the interactions are
sometimes 15 minutes oh no no no I have
pretty much like like for example I have
clients that I'm with you told you told
me you just got through with a week
right yes one week so um usually I don't
really
do one hour two hour because I have so
much options maybe but um minimum at
least 3 hours to overnight which which
is very often mhm overnights and
obviously more couple days and and your
clients are married or single or uh well
usually there
are married
or single business women so they don't
have time to be in a relationship pretty
much and or maybe they try being in a
relationship but the relationship is not
as the quality of it is not as they
expect to
be so yeah so that's why I'm there
you're from Europe you're correct you're
from Poland
Poland what was your childhood like
growing up in
Poland so um so my parents uh got
divorced when I was two years old I
think so obviously I was not imp
plant and um my mom came to United
States when when I I was two so I didn't
see my mom
for until I was 11 years
old I didn't even know how she back then
they didn't have internet obviously and
my father was just traveling around the
Europe you know just working or doing
whatever he wanted to do so who raised
me was pretty much my aunt and my
grandma
which you know they were not like in my
life so I could do whatever I want when
I was three four five six 7 years old I
had friends that were 18 19 years old so
I didn't have like a curfew I mean I had
but I didn't care um you know I was just
living learning
from individuals that pretty much were
kids so that's not a good influence and
this this was where in Poland in Poland
and then I moved to New York City when I
was
11 Meanwhile my 11 years old was
thinking already like I'm 20 something
years old which is very obviously
unhealthy and especially in New York so
I had friends that were most of my
friends were uh I would
say individuals that
were very not um good to the Human
Society there were obviously um bad
individuals um they didn't know but they
were not the best ones and yeah and from
there I just you know that was my family
more the friends were my family so from
there
um I was doing bad stuff when it comes
to I was a drug
dealer uh I was uh hulligan which is
somebody that's you know just like a
gang member or
something from there I was so was many
characters in in my life from there I
was then I I got tired of drug dealing
so I was doing stock market which I was
pretty good at it and but the thing is
what I
because being like a I guess a hooligan
or a drug dealer somebody that's doesn't
obey the law it's like a drug too
because you have the power you have
people are are you know are intimidated
by you especially in my community in New
York the Polish I was very
known I'm I'm still yeah but I don't
want to be around that community so
probably pretty much I don't know what's
happening now but so I was very known in
that community and my the group of
people I was surrounded myself were very
known in New York in New Jersey and
Chicago so but I didn't like the
lifestyle because I didn't like me as a
human being I was a horrible human being
uh and so yeah so I started the trading
stock market I was really successful but
a
friend uh
guess a friend of a friend wanted to do
some business so I went into uh uh
cigarette smuggling
business uh so from that it was also
very
lucrative we would say I don't know I
was making 60,000 a week it was insane
money but obviously it's also
illegal and then I got taking advantage
of the individual and from that I was
facing prison
time which was three and a half years
and from
that pretty much uh I got to be a
entrepreneur slash
companionship slash just enjoying my
life fully in all ways as possible and
yeah so you're young you're
younger childhood you didn't have your
mom and dad no your aunts and my aunts
and and my grandma but see in Poland is
a little bit different like I could do
whatever I
want because especially the the place I
was in Poland is not really a big city
place or it's like a town let's say
mhm so I could do whatever I want I
didn't have to you know listen to
anybody especially when you're are maybe
like a little child boy
you you're listening more to your
friends because you want to be liked by
them and they want to be liked by you so
yeah do you think that like a rebel yeah
do you think that childhood somehow may
have led
you into what you're doing
now um probably
yes I would say
so because um I never like to I mean I
went to college I graduated I went to
high school all that I I never liked a
regular
job uh I always wanted to be
independent since I was a kid obviously
I had to be independent so let's say you
know buying stuff for me or taking care
of myself so that's actually like a
aspect you in a way like you being Your
Own Boss let's
say so yeah definitely I would say
so so it's it has to be like you say
it's not for everyone because you have
to have the the mindset the grid the you
know everything has to come up since
you're a child or
say and then you can do pretty much when
you're older you you understand the
world differently it's like a curtain is
open and then you see what is it
about and are you saving money are you
you are you living comfortably I would
say so yes very comfortably how did you
get into this line of work uh well I
love sex that's one it doesn't make you
unique doesn't make me unique at all but
um I
guess I like to please maybe that's
why and I enjoy it it's not just the
money it's more I likely enjoy doing it
so maybe that's why I'm a good so good
at it do you love women oh I love women
definitely I think that's a big plus
yes cuz some
men I think deep down don't like
women probably or they they they value
them very low MH you know I value them
way higher than men maybe that's
why uh but yes I love
women and you've you've been in Ro
romantic relationships that are oh yeah
I I was married before you're married I
was married before uh 5 years married um
we were together 10 years uh we separ
well we separated maybe I didn't want to
be with her anymore
because we had a different
goals and
Lifestyles so that's why probably we
separated
mhm yeah but other than that
um since I was a kid I pretty much
didn't have a lot
of relationship mostly was uh friends
with benefits as you can call since I
was a little so maybe that's why I'm so
used to and comfortable and maybe you
have the I don't
know uh personality to to fit that
description how many female clients do
you have or will you have at a time you
have you have regulars that will call
you back oh yes I have um some that are
very I would say even more than just a
client it's more more like a
friendship so you know we just say hi
how was your day and all that it's not
like um it's more than just time and
money but usually yes I have a
lot I don't know the count
is I don't even know but it's a lot I'm
sure and and when you when you get
together with a client is there always
sex involved or sometimes not sex uh
pretty much there's most of the time
it's sex involved but uh sometimes in
the beginning like let's say if I meet
with a client they just want a lot of
sex and it's for
hours but uh one obviously the next day
or the next they actually want uh like a
companion just hang out go on a date uh
do something interesting go on a show so
it's more like a boyfriend experience
and obviously sex included but it's less
than sex then and and you're you're a
very handsome young man are the women
sometimes not as attractive as you're
uh would would like them to be for me or
personally for me uh well the here's the
thing for me it's uh because I had so
many women in my life so it's not about
the
looks uh it's more about the personality
the person that's what I love especially
intelligent women that's what I love
about that's great yes and
um and pretty much when it comes to my
um well my I guess when it comes to my
looks I like you know Buddhas women
that's my uh everyone's thing that's my
type exactly I had all of them but
that's my type so every guy's got a type
exactly I think every I think guys have
a physical type that they're attracted
to and
women operate very differently exactly
don't you think m mhm where where a
woman can be attracted to any type of
guy big strong weak thin
smart as as soon as they get emotionally
attached then they become physically
attracted yes and well here's the thing
with me uh I think I have issues is
women get very emotionally attached to
me even though if it's a
client so it's very thin line when I
have to like you know uh explain I guess
what's the Arrangement is but they get
very um attached all the time which
that's the issues that I'm having
problem with but obviously it's not a
bad problem but it is a problem because
it is a problem because then it's you
know I don't obviously I don't want to I
guess break nobody's heart or you know
I'm here to uh but if you're doing a
good job the woman gets attached
attached yes well you live you you
learn and you make good money doing that
definitely
mhm the guys are going to be like how do
I get this job uh well I don't think
it's for
it's I think it's when you look at it
for the money perspective then it's
harder
um I was already I
guess well financially before I was
doing it so how is what you do different
than what a a prostitute does with her
client sometimes those those
interactions are very short yes they
have their sex it's very clearly you
know prostitution is illegal here in the
United States so those those
interactions are
probably very illegal probably yes by in
the eyes of the law exactly that the
morals of it all is very different
conversation but what is how is what you
do different than what the women are
doing with men well uh what I do is
individuals try to gain contact with me
either through email
through social media a
lot um text obviously if I have a number
or or if I promote myself but that
usually I don't really I guess call or
ask anyone there's so much demand I
guess maybe for me or in general that
individuals have contact me and then I
have to fill them out filter them out if
if it's a right fit if if I if it's
worth it if if pretty much you screen
them yes I have to screen them and women
do have to do that too but they do it
for the safety I do it for if it's the
right fit for me if I have the time if
how how will you screen them will you
see a photo will you uh I asked them
questions uh pretty much what they're
into if if it's let's say if it's about
money if it's in their budget
and and obviously sometimes individuals
say no and I'm I'm happily not
negotiable I just say okay that's fine
with me not a good fit not a good fit
I'm sure you can find somebody else and
they are actually very shocked because
they think I can they could probably
negotiate with me which will not work
but it's funny how it is and yes and
from there there if if there's more text
then I send them photos they send me
some photos and from there if I like it
then we can
meet and then here's the thing if I like
the uh first encounter then I can meet
but usually if I don't like it even if
it was okay I say next time no so it's
very for me it's very different because
I say no a lot constantly like even now
I'm let's say I'm going to meet somebody
after this interview and I had already
three and I had to say no no to two and
maybe one we'll see it's very
interesting how how the male female
Dynamic is so yes it's so different you
know with women you know I see I see
what happens on Figaroa Street which is
a big prostitution prostitution track on
uh okay in Los Angeles and uh the guys
roll up they see a girl they like they
they negotiate the girl gets in the car
and they go yeah exactly that's it it's
very dangerous too yeah very dangerous
yeah and the guys decide they like with
the girl has to offer and they run off
and do their do their transaction with
you it's you know with you know men
selling sex is is ridiculous it is
because every guy wants sex and every
girl is basically holding out to yeah
pretty much get what that's their uh I
guess that's their Hook when it comes to
men because when men wants you can look
at it that way sure exactly and women
they play hard to get let's
say that's their I think tactic so so
what what what are you offering that
makes a woman Say Hey I want this H well
I think I know how to
persuade
individuals
very I know how to ask the questions
that they want to
answer and from
there I'm being honest with them maybe
that I don't like to sugar coat or
promise them I don't know what
and you're not sweet talking them no no
no you have to be very honest and
respectful
too and once they realize that you are
honest and respectful they be they they
trust you because obviously I'm sure
there's I'm I'm not the only one in New
York especially so there's a little bit
I would say like I say people need to if
they care more like I care so I will
give them my time and while we talk
and they it's very rare when people give
them time because that all they need is
money usually let's say on my side is
they thinking about money not the
experience I'm thinking about the
experience first and then I think about
the money so that's my I charge maybe a
little bit more
because I deserve it in a
way then that's
why what were you doing before uh
trading stock market and I had
businesses uh retail businesses and how
did this how did you make the transition
into this
um I
guess like I said I loved
sex and uh yeah and oh and I was uh well
the main thing well that's the main
thing I was about to get
incarcerated so for me I was thinking
okay I need to get sex as much as
possible because you're gonna go to jail
yes so then for what um well there was
many things but it was mainly because
um my business partner stole a lot of
money from me and I uh beat him up
really
bad and yeah and all that came from from
that
so pretty much that's why I I wanted to
oh try something you know if I'm going
to be away I need to get as much sex as
possible
so that worked but it never works out
you always want more sex but uh and then
from there I'm like oh that I'm really
good at it and I I I enjoy it so why
not yeah and the women will range from
different ages young and old yes um some
of them my age uh most of them in the in
the 40s some of they older like
50s but yes some between 40s I guess I'm
34 so I'm not that young yet I
mean it's all relative the it's all
relative the women will be married I
mean some of them I'm sure are married
and they know their husbands are doing
something on the side so they're doing
the same oh definitely definitely or
even maybe they're not even doing
nothing on the side but they just don't
care about them um pretty much you know
when you I don't know people when they
get I guess in a relationship they get
very comfortable and they don't put the
work so probably that's probably the
reason why also you know what what have
you learned about romantic relationships
that you can apply to your own life one
day maybe when you meet someone
um well you need to care about the other
person bad or good and you have to even
when you don't like something about the
individual either their personality or
maybe their dislikes or like you still
have to care and accept them for who
they are and if you accept the person
for who they are then you actually will
not care about the
negative stuff let's say you will care
out the positive stuff and you make a
grow from there and and have an amazing
relationship MH that's great advice yeah
do you uh do you foresee doing this for
many years or is this temporary uh well
I don't know it's been five
years so it's been some time
um unless I will feel like I have
to do it uh like because I I need to do
it then probably I would not do it but
if I enjoy doing it here's the thing
about doing it because it's not only
just obviously the money or the
experiences it's also meeting
interesting individuals so you meet
interesting individuals and you get
friendship and you know it's it's like
you grow in your network let's say so
it's more than just you know now it's
more in the future what what could
happen and what could
be and it's feasible that one day you'll
have a client who you to could be very
could be could you could I could fall in
love deeply and yeah and settle maybe
but here's the thing I I like to be non-
monogamous so uh I'm sure I would never
I mean I tried it obviously I was
married but I'm sure I would never uh be
uh in a monogamous relationship so maybe
I could be in a relationship but it's
going to be non monogamous which it
means I will date other individuals
right and she could too obviously open
marriage exactly so an open relationship
open relationship yeah so I will still
love the individual but obviously I will
date and let's say have sexual pleasures
with other do you do you think humans
are just not meant to
be in a monogamous relationship you know
monogamous forever uh I mean depends who
I I personally think serial monogamy
maybe serial monogamy maybe back in the
day it was working but now
you know people like for example me I
was in a
relationship I was I was very I was
always faithful in my marriage I would
say even even little things like let's
say I was hanging out with my friend and
you know a beautiful woman's passing by
I would never even talk to her or even
turn around I would be I would be very
and I had many opportunities Also let's
say be
unfaithful but I never did that and I
tell you the truth it would be
I'm sure the relationship would be much
better and more uh if let's say I would
have uh sexual pleasure with other women
so then maybe even though let's say you
have sex with somebody but then you are
you Miss let's say your love and you
really deeply want to have sex because
it's way different when you in love or
making love than it's a sex like night
and day oh definitely yeah you know so
that would actually make the
relationship even more probably stronger
from that in my opinion
mhm do you get do you ever get caught by
by the
husbands no not really to tell you the
truth here's the thing about the
husbands I even have clients the
husbands give them gifts as meat to
their wives oh really like they boo the
whole day or let's say there's a husband
sitting in the room and watching me
having sex with with his wife that's
amazing relationship by the way but you
see how it is so it's it's depends on
many different types many different
types
yes what does your typical date look
like you guys go out to dinner and you
have long conversations or well it
depends for how long if it's for the
whole day then it's just like anything
it's you waking up um morning you know
either I could make breakfast or we
could both make breakfast um kissing
touching uh sex obviously in the kitchen
or anywhere whatever they whatever
happens and then from there we probably
go on go on a date like do something
together it could be uh go work out go
jogging on the beach uh doing yoga
together going to a
class and then from there dinner and
probably hang out or maybe a show
usually a lot of
shows and yeah passionate
sex again
again uh probably at least three or four
times a day um sometimes well that's if
it's an overnight date obviously if it's
for U 3 hours or two hours is mostly
constantly sex little bit talking
cuddling but constantly sex a lot of
coming for me
it's a physical job for you it's very uh
it's a workout definitely you have to be
very fit stamina and you have to know
how to control um you know the senses of
you know and you have to practice and
when you practice you you'll be better
at
it the longest interaction the the
longest date you've had has been what
how how long will you be get get booked
for
uh
about a week or so because that usually
it's up to me too so I don't really want
longer because like with with say with
me I have a lot of clients I cannot just
drop everything and and you know be with
one person because then you know pretty
much I will not spend with other people
and it's like you have to manage the
time
of basically nurture all the
relationship so it will be you know
equally does it get difficult to like so
you're on a date with a one woman for 3
Days say yes and then the other ones are
calling you and they want to talk and
they want to exactly have just a full
phone interaction so I usually um I
usually text and sometimes call
but I always have like a communication
if I don't reply that means I'm I'm
probably with somebody or and they they
know and they're perfectly
understandable they don't and obviously
the individuals that I'm with they're
very busy individuals like extremely
busy so they they understand uh how to
respect somebody's
time you ever get burnt
out
uh I need like at least let's say a day
off uh I'm
obviously very fit and I um put amazing
fuel in my body so and maybe genetic I'm
very good at a lot of stuff so maybe not
really maybe I'm more borned off maybe
uh because I'm an introvert too which is
very weird I like space for myself let's
say in my house and just you know just
relax so I have to manage everything and
yeah and how much money do you I mean
because you're not you're not going
you're not whining and dining these
women because the money is coming is
flowing in your direction not theirs
exactly correctly so you're you're take
you're you're taking them out but
there're they're paying yes mhm
sometimes I do pay too because I like to
I like to pay as well it's not just me
me me me me because I like to give too
but in the end of the get together
they're writing you a check or they're
they're sending you a large payment yes
how much is that payment typically well
depends for the days usually my
overnight is not really that much it's
1,250 I think it's people um pay
more um for let's say a week is mostly
$8,000 so it's not bad but
it's what what advice can you give to
men who are in relationships or are
dating MH that they just don't seem to
understand what their girl wants what
their partner wants I think everybody's
selfish they selfish with their time and
they're they're not aware enough of
let's say if you have somebody that
really loves you and cares about you and
are willing to spend time with you
you're supposed to also spend time with
them and be more aware instead of you
know being on social media maybe or
watching a TV let's say a lot of I
noticed from my previous relationship
let's say you're in a room by you're
watching TV together and you're not
really communicating you're just
watching something together so it's not
really you know you're not really
together even though you are in the same
space so be more you know try to learn
about the other
individual
and and
Care pretty much don't be
selfish yeah I think that's that's a
common problem yes everybody is just me
me me me me me maybe I have it easier
because I know I'm getting some value of
obviously when it comes to money
and I guess I'm looking on the big
picture uh because I'm also very picky
with who I meet it's not just I pick
anyone and at first obviously we have a
chat what what they like if I'm I can
even provide that and if I want to and
and then we go from there so I'm looking
out if I want to surround myself women
that are very um sameem minded
individual open-minded individuals you
know
intelligent and and then I go from there
do you get women complaining about their
their Partners their husbands uh what
they're not providing yes a lot so
that's that's me coming in when I'm like
the therapist in a way and obviously I'm
not the kind of person that obviously
give the advice to anyone if I wouldn't
be in their shoes if I I was thinking if
I would be in the shoes what would I do
and I I like I wouldn't say I would
cross the individual out just you
know communicate pretty much and go from
there you must have some interesting
stories of how these interactions have
gone these dates have gone yes um tell
me a story or two of okay um I have a
story let's say uh woman once which is
very uh interesting a lot of women I I
was surprised
that they want somebody let's say when
you let's say you meet in a hotel okay I
come in and they don't want now uh in
communication just basically they want
me just to rip her clo off and basically
feel like she's being used which is
obviously turns individuals like let's
say I'm not trying to be uh dominant or
anything but it turns everybody out
because it's like more um sensitive
so they like rough sex a lot of rough
sex like basically like you almost are
taking advantage of them and and that's
what they into I don't know why maybe
that was that's their like fantasies
like obviously almost like being
raped maybe not like being raped but
very close to that kind of uh you know
experience they like rough
um uh smacking a lot of stuff like that
choking
choking and but they also obviously at
the end they they want more cuddling and
more love but that's their first their
their first uh fantasy that they would
like to have just rough not even have
say hi or bye you just go and basically
like taking advantage of them so that's
one of their
experience some other experiences like
um
they would like to have sex in a public
somewhere so it could be let's say we
are the restaurant and under the table
you know we're massaging each other and
then we go to the bathroom and just have
wild sex so they have um that kind of
fantasies as well which is in the public
in a
way um
yeah everyone's got their little Kink
everybody has their little Kink yes
which is fine you know that's what they
want that's their desires that they want
to make it come true so they that's why
they call me emotionally what does this
kind of work do for a young man like
yourself
emotionally uh it makes me um learn
about human behavior how it works which
is I'm always like to learn stuff
especially about humans so it makes me
realize how you know
individuals I guess think in their mind
and
obviously how they I guess try to
live in this world of
ours and you can see their lives you
know their private lives and then their
secret lives and then their public
life so it's very interesting you know
when I ask women about what they've
female sex workers what they've learned
about men they often say that men are
very simple oh really yeah the men men
are just very basic and simple very very
easy to figure out yes what would you
say you've learned about
women it depends like for example if I
it was I would just be starting out then
obviously you have to understand what is
their first desires and how do they
think but so in the beginning they feel
like complex too but then like for
example me I already is very it's also
very basic cuz everybody pretty much
want the same thing at the end which is
pleasure and connection and feel some
kind of um chemistry that you really
care about them and that's all and if
they get that Tipsy of that the the high
of that then they can live their lives
and be you know normal and then
obviously after time like everything
every like everything is a in a way is
like a drug so once you get it then you
want more or you know you want
better pretty
much how what what percentage of the
women that you're are your clients are
married I would
say maybe
70% yes we're all Unfaithful aren't we
pretty
much
in one ways
yes what does that make you think about
the just the the nature of relationships
between men and
women are they all doomed to uh fall
apart
eventually uh well it
depends or or or or lead to some open
relationship that's the thing probably
will lead to some open relationship
especially if it's a you know older
relationship if uh they just communicate
what they want and their desires and
accept both of their uh I guess goals
then they will have amazing
relationship but the thing is if they're
secretive that's probably what ruins the
relationship is the the the secret the
secret and then maybe the secret comes
out or maybe from that secret let's say
they're being secret about
let's say being unfaithful but then
that's like a habit they get they
they're not sharing other stuff and then
that ruins the
relationship it's just miscommunication
that's all it is I think if they would
communicate better then they will have a
better relationship in their lives and
outside of their
relationship yeah that's that's good
advice yeah all right Tom thank you so
much for sharing your thoughts and
experiences thank you very interesting
of course I wish you lots of luck with
your with your career yes thank you very
much thank you all
right